مره نحو عام ونصف على سيطره حركه طالبان
على افغانستان مده لم تتوقف خلال لها
الحركه عن مفاجاه المجتمع الدولي بقرارات
لاقت انتقادا واسعا سيما في حق المراه
التي سلبت الكثير من حقوقها الاساسيه
فماذا يحدث تحديدا داخل الحركه التي ابدت
في البدايه استعدادا للتخلي عن بعض
قوانينها الصارمه بحثا عن اعتراف دولي لكن
شيئا من ذلك لم يحدث بهذا الخصوص عزل
صحيفه واشنطن بوست قرارات المنع الاخيره
في حق المراه الى سيطره المجموعه المتشدده
على حركه طالبان تقول الصحيفه وقالت ايضا
ان سلسله من القرارات التي اتخذتها طالبا
تتجاوز رغبات بعض مسؤولين الحركه بالعاصمه
[موسيقى]
السؤال المطروح الان من يتخذ القرارات
الحاسمه داخل الحركه تقول الصحيفه ان مركز
القرار داخل حركه طالبان ليس في كابول بل
تحول الى قندهار فالمرشد الاعلى لطالبان
هيبه الله اخون زاده وزملائه من صقور
طالبان يتخذ يتخذون القرارات الكبرى من
قندهار اين يقيمون ورغم تعيين وزراء في
كابول الا ان المرشد الاعلى تبقى له
الكلمه الاخيره في جميع القرارات هذا
الكلام عزيزته الصحيفه بتصريح لاحد
المسؤولين في طالبان يؤكد فيه ان اي قرار
مهم لابد من الحصول فيه على موافقه من
قندهار منبها الى ان العديد من الاحكام لا
تحظى بموافقه المسؤولينا في كابول
طالبان استبعاد متواصل للنساء من الحياه
العامه
اكتوبر 2021 منوع غالبيه الموظفات
الحكوميه من القدوم الى العمل
مارس 2022 منع الفتيات من التعليم الثانوي